(audience clapping)
- Hello. Nice to meet you.
- Hello. Hi.
- I love your outfit so much.
- Thank you, thank you.
- [Kelly] Y'all look so cute.
Well, you know Michelle of course.
- I do know her.
- Yeah. What up.
- So we were talking about
best snacks in America.
What are some of your favorite snacks?
- Um let's see, I think I,
well pizza.
- [Kelly] Pizza's pretty good.
I think Anchovy Pizzas always mine.
- [Kelly] I'm sorry.
(Michelle laughing)
- [Kelly] Whoa.
- What, what.
- Anchovy Pizza.
- Yeah. I mean that's, it's
a Brooklyn thing, right?
It's a New York delicacy.
- Well Pizza's for sure a Brooklyn thing.
- Yeah.
- Whoa.
- I don't know about the anchovies though.
- It's weirdly hard to
find even in New York.
I didn't think it was such a weird thing.
- It's the anchovies, I think.
- I dunno.
- I'm gonna try it just cause
it's a dare I feel to myself.
- I enjoy it.
- Okay, okay.
- So when did you start
acting? You're pretty young.
- Uh, yeah. When did I start acting?
Well, I started a while ago.
I think I started when
I was like eight, nine.
I took some classes at Strasberg.
- That's early.
- What I know. What made
you wanna do acting?
- I don't know. I
(all laughing)
- Oh my God, I love you.
- It was a Tuesday, I saw a pamphlet.
- My, my stepfather, uh, uh, he,
uh, he's a lawyer
but he really loves photography
and he's an amazing photographer.
And when I was like seven he took like
a cinematography class and he had me,
there we are.
- [Kelly] Aww
- That's great.
- [Kelly] Oh, look at the little munchkin.
- [Sophia] And, he had me drag
that wagon around New York.
- [Kelly] I love your outfit.
- Thank you, Thank you.
- Oh, dude that's awesome.
- Yeah, it was.
- And your cute haircut with it.
- Yeah. So that happened.
(audience laughing)
- So wait, you did this
for him for a class,
and then it kind of stuck.
- Yeah, he, he said he would give me,
allow me to go to McDonald's after.
- Oh my God, So you're my son.
He is the same way.
- Yeah, so
- Anything for those fries.
- Yeah.
- So you're both in the new
Dungeons and Dragons movie
so I love the movie by the way.
You did such a great job.
- Oh, thank you.
And I will say I love
both of your characters
but I love yours
cuz you're like an owl and a bear at once
- Dude so cool.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- She's my favorite character too.
- It's like you morph into
all these different things
that you like need to be and I was like,
that's an incredible superpower.
- Thank you.
- Yeah. I like your character a lot.
Did you like? Because a lot of it's CGI,
so did you have to do any kind of
I don't know, background for that?
You have to walk like a bear or anything?
- Yeah. Well, well, well, well you see,
I didn't know if they were gonna
do like the CGI whole thing
so I, you know, prepared just in case.
So a lot of...
- Oh my God, so all your work.
- Animal documentaries and
like, how does this bear move?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah. So I I did that.
- Did you even, did you
try out for the fly?
I mean, not to give
anything away, but, you know
an owlbears not the only
thing she can turn into.
- It's true. I turn into
a variety of animals.
It really...
- That wizardry, that
kind of magic was cool.
- [Sophia] Mm.
- [Kelly] I've never seen that.
- Their dungeon masters
by the way, the directors
- [Kelly] Yeah. Oh, they are.
- Like they played so much
that they're dungeon masters.
- It was very fitting
with, with D and D too.
That's like basically what you do in,
when you play it's like...
- Absolutely.
- Oh, I have this amazing idea.
And they like try to, and
it's a different world.
- Well you pick a power and
every power has a range of,
to its limitations, you know?
- Yeah.
- And, and in between you've
got so much that you can do.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I mean barbarians, you
know, they're pretty limited
compared to a lot of the other characters,
but we've magicians that can
pull so much out of that magic.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you've got rogues
that can do so much.
Druids, Tieflings,
- Right.
- and Tiefling owlbears.
- Yeah.
- You know, it's like pretty wild.
- It is. I love all the characters.
Your character has horns.
So, how did that go over and a tail?
- They kept falling off.
- [Kelly] They kept falling off?
- They did
- The tail was CGI.
- the tale was CGI cuz they made,
I'm not saying this on camera.
(all laughing)
They made an actual...
- The fake tale didn't work
out, just put it that way.
- No, it didn't work out.
- Oh, they made a tail
that you had to wear?
- [Michelle] It looked weird.
- It looked strange it
was really, it was big.
It was on my back.
- In the way.
- It was protruding from my back
- It Was just in the way everywhere.
- Just whenever I walked it
Just really just whacked people.
They were like, this is a terrible idea.
So, that didn't work out.
- What about your horns,
was it like a headband?
- Man. The horns were good or
- They were magnetic?
- They were magnetic.
So, I had like a little
contraption on my head
and then they had little two holes
in my wig that, so when
it came out, the, the...
- [Kelly] So a magnet, it
would pop off pretty easily.
- Oh.
- Yeah
Oh
- Yeah.
- And take two!
- We're gonna have to do that again.
One of my horns is over there.
- Like It got a little
wonky at some points, so.
- Well it looked good.
- Thank, Thank you.
- [Kelly] Yeah, Well done in the end.